ANTETOKOUNMPO.
YOU GOT JA MORANT.
JA, THAT DUNK YOU HAD IN THE
FIRST HALF, ALAN TRIED TO COPY
IT.
THAT FIRST-HALF DUNK YOU HAD WAS
ABSOLUTELY SPECTACULAR.
HAD YOU BEEN PLANNING THAT?
THINKING ABOUT THAT?
WHERE DID THAT COME FROM?
>> OH, I JUST DECIDED WHAT TO
DO.
>> JA, WE GOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET ON THE STAGE AND TAKE A
PHOTO, MAN.
TELL ME HOW THAT FELT.
DID YOU ENVISION YOURSELF BEING
ON THAT STAGE IN 25 YEARS?
>> YOU KNOW, IT WAS AN HONOR
JUST TO BE A PART OF THAT,
SEEING SO MANY GREAT PLAYERS,
THE BEST TO EVER PLAY THE GAME.
YOU'RE HONORED HERE TONIGHT AND
ME JUST BEING A PART OF IT IS A
BLESSING, MAN.
HOPEFULLY IN 25 YEARS I'LL BE
SHARING THAT STAGE WITH YOU
GUYS.
>> JA, THIS IS REGGIE.
I'M BEGGING, I'M PLEADING,
PLEASE, PLEASE NEXT YEAR IF
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT DUNK
CONTEST AS A FINAL EVENT, YOU
GOT TO BE PART -- PLEASE,
PLEASE, PLEASE!
YOU WOULD BRING DOWN THE HOUSE.
>> FOR SURE BUT I